were you a big Hitchcock guy I'm not a
Hitchcock fan really yeah yeah I
normally don't like the third acts of
his movies now some of them I do and
this is just my opinion they oftentimes
they they Peter out and he's not quite
able to end them like you know the way I
think he would have if he was coming if
he was if he was the age he was in the
50s in the 70s I think his I would I
would appreciate his films more uh I
think he's held back by the haze code I
think he was really truly held back by
the haze code now at the same time
he was a clever little bugger all right
so because he uh uh uh he could use the
haze code against their own selves from
time to time uh one of my actually
favorite Hitchcock endings seems to be a
compromise forced on him but then he
subverts the compromise there's a
there's a an expression in Hebrew called
which means like a reverse on a reverse
and he kind of does a Fook at the end of
the movie suspicion but it'll be
different now we'll make it different